the opening scene features a stock
broker named Ryan Hines who wakes up
inside an empty cell tied to a chair he
has no idea where he is or how he got
there he somehow manages to free himself
from the restraints but still remains
trapped because the heavy metal door is
locked Ryan then looks out through a
small glass window but finds no signs of
anyone nearby a short while later he
receives a call from his friend Bruce
who pleads with him for help upon
inquiring further about his predicament
Ryan learns that his friend is also
captured in the same manner but in a
different cell Bruce tells him that he's
been kidnapped for ransom money Ryan
asks if he has any recollection from
earlier to which Bruce replies that he
only remembers partying with Ryan and
two women in a hotel room the previous
night just then Bruce starts screaming
in pain yelling that he is burning out
before their call is cut off Ryan hears
a burning sound from the other end it
sounded like
this amidst Bruce's scream indicating
that his friend was burnt to death this
terrifies Ryan and he pleads to be let
out moments later a disguised voice over
a speaker addresses Ryan asking for his
full attention presumably it's the
kidnapper The Voice offers Ryan his
freedom in exchange for guessing the
kidnapper's name correctly within 2
minutes is it
John yeah however Ryan who is
frustrated attempts to break the glass
window using a chair The Voice claims
that he is only wasting his time Ryan
then tries to think of the names of
wealthy investors he met the day before
he tries hard and recalls the name of
three of them but all of them prove to
be the wrong answers as a result of this
his freedom is denied and the cell
starts to heat up at 100° Ryan asks the
kidnapper to switch it off but he is
completely ignored he also tries to turn
it off by himself but to no avail with
no other choice Ryan decides to comply
with the kidnapper agreeing to whatever
he wants following this the heaters are
turned off for the time being and Sam is
released through the fan The Voice then
Demands a ransom of $1 million within 2
hours warning that the room's
temperature will keep increasing every 5
minutes until the funds are transferred
Ryan tries to explain that he belongs to
a middleclass family with a wife and a
7-year-old son and that he does not have
that much money however the voice does
not care and warns that failing to do so
will result in burning him dry feeling
utterly helpless reaches out to his
estranged brother John oh his name's
John actually can't believe that he
serves as a police Sergeant he confides
in John about his dire situation the
latter is initially upset that he hasn't
spoken to him in such a long time but he
agrees to help him he instructs Ryan to
keep his phone on so that his team can
trace his location and mount a rescue
operation after hanging up the phone the
voice asks Ryan if he really thinks his
brother can help him out through this
Ryan is shocked that the voice knows
whom he called but he opts to remain
silent a while later Ryan tries to offer
his precious watch worth
$10,000 which was given to him by his
father however the voice refuses to
accept this and instead orders him to
smash it on the floor desperate to raise
the ransom money Ryan contacts his wife
Anna and asks her to transfer their
entire savings to a specified account
she initially hesitates and asks several
questions honey it sounds like they're
going to kill you anyway maybe I should
just keep the money but Ryan doesn't
answer any of them insisting that she
simply do what he says following this he
calls his mother to request some money
however his mother complains about Ryan
never calling her unless there's
something he needs from her this enrages
Ryan who reminds her about the monthly
checks he sends to her after a brief
discussion he ultimately manages to
convince her nevertheless he remains
short of the required amount and resorts
to reaching out to friends and other
relatives after some time Ryan receives
a call from John who tells him that he
has arrived at the location with his
SWAT team this excites Ryan so he shouts
and pounds on the doors in an attempt to
pinpoint his exact whereabouts however
his relief is short lived when Jon calls
again to inform that they are at the
wrong location as Ryan's phone signal
has been rerouted to a different place
Jon further informs him that they only
found an abandoned warehouse with a note
that reads I have them in hopes of
finding another alternative JN asks him
to recall any details prior to his
kidnapping but Ryan whose Hope Has
shattered and the call fearing for his
family safety Ryan calls his wife who
appears to be scared she claims that
someone is outside their house and their
son Larry is still at school Ryan
instructs her to stay hidden and call
the police just then the voice asserts
that every wrong action has consequences
after which the room's sprinklers in the
room activate showering boiling water on
him in response Ryan begs for
forgiveness and promises that he will
get the money prompting the water to
stop Ryan then begins to call call his
wealthy investors and clients using his
persuasive tactics to encourage them to
invest in various businesses he
guarantees them attractive returns and
fabricates multiple stories to convince
them to send him money as the room's
temperature continues to rise he begins
to lose his mind at one point he
collapses to the ground and experiences
a vision of himself dismantling the
heater above him a few moments later
Ryan's phone rings snapping him out of
his dream it's johon on the line once
again inquiring about the last thing he
recalls before the incident Ryan
recounts checking out of the hotel after
a night of partying and as he got into
his car someone grabbed him from behind
rendering him unconscious Jon then asks
him to hold on as they are narrowing
down his location even though Ryan's
story couldn't have possibly been any
less helpful after this Ryan resumes
reaching out to his clients gradually
collecting the funds after multiple
calls and numerous false assurances Ryan
successfully accumulates $1 million in
his account he promptly shows the money
and asks the kidnapper's account number
for the transfer however the kidnapper
refuses to accept it asserting that Ryan
was supposed to transfer his own money
not someone else's the kidnapper says
that he is well aware of the $4 million
that Ryan secretly set aside for himself
now that he has cheated he won't be
allowed to get out of this place hearing
this Ryan apologizes and pleads for
another chance The Voice agrees but now
Ryan will have to transfer all $4
million within 5 minutes Ryan pleads for
another way out saying that the money is
for his family's future however the
kidnapper refuses to listen to him and
the increasing room temperature forces
him to comply he transfers all of his
money to the specified account before
passing out due to the heat after a
while Ryan regains Consciousness and
notices that the room's temperature has
dropped he crawls toward the fan and sze
with relief after taking a moment to
recover Ryan asks to be released as he
has fulfilled all the kidnappers demands
however the voice refuses saying that
they still have unfinished business to
discuss subsequently a piece of paper
slides through the door slot which has a
list of his family members names Ryan is
instructed to read the names aloud and
clarify their relationships complying
with this Ryan begins reading the names
Anna Larry John Valerie and gray who are
his wife son brother Mother and Father
respectively just then he pauses when he
comes to the name Leslie The Voice
inquires about her but Ryan
remains silent shortly after he receives
a call from Anna whose voice trembles
with fear Ryan asks about her
whereabouts and she describes a room
resembling the one he's trapped in this
makes him realize that she too has been
kidnapped while talking Anna hears the
kidnapper's voice and questions his
identity The Voice instructs her to pose
the same question to her husband the
kidnapper then presses Ryan to unveil
his true identity to Anna he is
reluctant at first but the increasing
Heat forces him to comply he then
reveals that he has dozens of aliases to
deceive people and persuade them to
invest in various businesses for his own
gain he's this big of a worm and he only
has $4 million a loser the kidnapper
also prompts him to disclose information
about Leslie but Ryan lacks the courage
to do so after this the kidnapper
directs Ryan's attention to a box in the
corner of the room urging him to open it
inside the ladder discovers a severed
human finger with a ring on it at the
same moment he hears Leslie's voice and
recognizes her instantly she reveals
that they abducted her and severed her
finger the kidnapper then initiates a
conference call between Ryan Anna and
Leslie compelling him to reveal his
secret to both women Ryan finally admits
that both of them are his wives moreover
he confesses that he only married Leslie
for money and that he doesn't care about
her however he claims to truly love Anna
and their son despite this shocking
Revelation Anna doesn't T her a word
probably because she's in shock or
because there are more twists coming and
she's actually a broom moments later
John calls Ryan notifying him that his
team will arrive in 15 minutes
regardless Ryan responds that it no
longer matters because everything is
already over then the kidnapper on the
speaker orders Ryan to pull out a gun
from the box and commit the unthinkable
if he does so his wives will be released
Ryan bravely places the gun to his head
and pulls the trigger on to discover
that it's unloaded this breaks him down
into tears and the cell door finally
opens as he steps out he is confronted
by his brother who turns out to be the
kid no way the kidnapper's name was John
dude it was a guess guys I was I just
came it was the first name that came to
mind JN then asks if he remembers the
day when he asked Ryan for a loan Jon
further asks if he knows the reason
behind asking for the loan when Ryan
answers in the negative his brother
discloses that it was for his son Adam
who was suffering from cancer but Ryan
refused to help without even asking for
the purpose why didn't Jon just tell him
that changing the topic Ryan inquires
about how Jon found out about the $4
million in response Jon reveals that he
discovered his brother's double life
when he was called to Leslie's house on
a robbery and that's where he saw their
wedding photos on the wall after hearing
all of this Ryan accuses him of killing
Bruce and torturing his wives solely for
his own gain however Jon denies being a
murderer revealing that they were all
part of the plan moments later Anna and
Leslie walk onto the scene and accuse
Ryan of Deceit Anna walks forward and
asks him if he really meant it when he
said he loves her to which he responds
with all of my heart consumed by
jealousy Leslie pulls her gun and shoots
Anna to death she then heads toward a
laptop to transfer the money to her
account only to discover that the funds
are gone Furious Leslie holds Ryan at
gunpoint and demands an explanation in
response he reveals that he had figured
out their plan so he feigned the fund
transfer hearing this Leslie is on the
verge of shooting him but Jon kills her
before she can pull the trigger with
only the two of them remaining Jon asks
about how Ryan knew it Ryan explains
that Anna made the first Mistake by
stating that she's also going to be
kidnapped when he had never told her
about his own abduction boy that was
sloppy next when the voice asked him to
destroy the watch he suspected that it
was John because he was always jealous
that their father gave it to him at last
Ryan recognized that the severed finger
did not belong to Leslie shocked Jon
asks how he knew the gun was unloaded
Ryan replies that this was the only
thing he didn't know and that he risked
his life because he didn't want Anna to
die are we supposed to sympathize for
this bag of in the aftermath of
all these Revelations Ryan locks up Jon
in the same cell alongside the other
dead bodies and turns on the heater
before walking away subscribe for more
videos like this turn turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching